The joe rogan experience.
It's funny because the things that I
thought used to be my weaknesses in this
new environment are actually
your biggest strengths.
Like I was kind of deeply insecure
back when I was a journalist.
Now I'm a journalist again
cause the congressional thing,
I think that was a little delusional on
my part to think that you can jump in
there and hope to have any kind of chance,
uh,
to,
to be taken seriously.
But,
uh,
now that I'm back to doing journalism,
the things that I used to be really
insecure about that I wasn't working for a
TV network and didn't have,
you know,
New York Times or NBC News after my name.
Those are actually your biggest
strengths today because people go,
Oh,
if,
if this guy knows about something,
he's not going to hold back.
He's going to do the research
and put it out there.
And the other thing that I'm not afraid
to do that I think more journalists
should do,
it's put things into
perspective for people.
People are busy.
You know,
I,
I sat there reading for this
boring national security
stuff and then I'm able to
pick out what's important
and tell people this matters.
And then sometimes people will tweet me
something that seems like a really big
deal and I'll debunk it.
I'm like,
actually it's problematic but it
probably doesn't matter because of a,
B and c and people need that cause
there's no sense of perspective anymore.
You go to the home page of Yahoo
and it's something about Obama,
some huge meeting with Merkel and Germany.
And then the next line,
right next to it is Kim Kardashians baby.
And then the line below that is
the Duggar family or the Doug,
ours,
whatever they're called that have 19 kids.
The reality TV horse,
it's them.
And so it fucks with your
mind cause you're like,
are these things all equally important?
These,
this is what's most important in the
world today are these three stories.
And you need people who are
not compromised by the system,
who have a no paycheck coming directly
from a news organization to just say,
yeah,
this is really important.
People should pay attention to it.
Or this is bullshit.
It's just being hyped and
it's not that big a deal.
Well,
essentially there's always going
to be a need for junk food.
Yeah.
And there's gonna be a need for
intellectual junk food as well.
And much like actual food.
If you offer people
intellectual junk food,
there's a certain group of us,
and I lump me in there as well that
will self sabotage and they will,
they will eat junk food and they will
have a cheeseburger and then this should
really have a salad and they will watch
intellectual junk food when maybe it
would do them better to sit down and
read a book or to watch Nova or to,
you know,
see a documentary.
There's sometimes you don't
want to watch a documentary.
You want to watch a bunch of
assholes bid on storage space,
you know,
and it doesn't,
it doesn't make any fucking sense.
And that's,
that's good too.
Like there's no reason that you have
to do serious stuff all day long.
You're right.
I,
uh,
I certainly don't subscribe to that,
but you're a balanced person.
And if you're an inbound person,
much like people would
just eat cheeseburgers,
you're going to have
intellectual junk food,
24,
seven.
You're going to be comforted.
Your mind will be occupied by nonsense.
And that's what we really need.
Our minds are designed to be
occupied by the pursuit of food,
sustenance and sexuality.
That's what we're after.
We're trying to find a place to arrest
someone to fuck something to eat,
keep going,
ready,
go get up in the morning.
Are you awake?
Okay,
fill the needs and now
those needs are filled.
Instead you're plugged into a fucking
video game and you're playing football
with some digital characters and you're
eating pizza that some guy actually
walked up to your fucking door and all
you need to do is give them some paper
that means almost nothing.
And he gives you pizza and you stuffing
your fat face and go right back to your
stupid game.
And it's so easy to do that.
It's so easy to do that.
As long as you can do enough to justify
enough ones and Zeros coming into your,
whatever your bank account is these days.
It's not the vault.
The vaults are filled with paper.
You know what's in that fucking fault?
It's vault filled with paper that's
promising something he promises inside.
Jason,
what kind of car do you drive it?
Dude,
I don't have a car and one
of those mother fuckers.
I'm in New York or New York.
You don't,
you don't drive cars.
I mean,
when I lived here I had a car.
I want to ask you about that Tesla.
Oh my God.
Is that the coolest thing of all time?
Incredible.
And they're only gonna get better.
I think they were about to release like
the third or fourth generation now.
Martine Rothblatt had one
and when I interviewed her
and I got to meet her robot
Bina 48.
Yeah.
You ever seen that?
Her,
her spouse as a robot,
Martine Rothblatt.
Fascinating story was a man,
wasn't man,
uh,
founded Sirius satellite radio,
got a sex change,
became a woman,
and then created a robot
that is a direct copy,
a duplicate of her spouse,
and it could really be how good it looks.
Well,
there she's there too.
Oh,
okay.
She's there as well.
I mean,
she just loves her,
so she made a robot for,
that's so sweet.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Liberace making that guy
changed his face to him.
Whoa.
You really do that.
Yeah.
They don't get plastic surgery.
Did you really do look more like Liberace?
That's hilarious.
He really is out in that the HBO thing.
Yeah.
I always wondered why Matt
Damon and Michael Douglas
were willing to do that and
if they have pictures of those,
too blown.
Yeah.
That's the only thing that makes sense.
Whether they agreed to do a live,
like if they came up to you when you were,
you were Matt Damon when they said,
hey,
listen,
man,
I know those Bourne identity movies,
they were really big and everything,
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Listen,
you're going to play Liberace's but buddy,
are you done made for TV made for TV?
Liberace,
his longtime lover,
but buddies,
very offensive.
By the way,
my gay friends,
and I apologize for that,
but pirate,
you guys are so immature.
I mean if you said that a
girl was your vagina pal,
does that be rude but giant of power?
No,
just be embarrassing.
Be Rude.
But isn't it interesting that a girl
can call a guy a dick and there's no
repercussions at all?
Their argument essay
and she can even say a,
I'm here to get,
get some good Jason Silva Dick.
And you wouldn't have
any problem with that.
You'd be like,
Yep,
I'm dishing it out honey.
But if a guy says,
oh,
I'm here to get some sweet Mary Pussy,
she'd be like,
what the fuck?
Cause really,
that's who I am.
I'm sweet Mary Pussy.
You don't think that's gross?
And you're like,
oh my God,
you're not really my friend.
Can't even joke around with you.
Jason,
what do you think's going to happen?
These checks Android's.
What do you see as the future?
Well,
I think,
I think the sex does sex technology
will probably be the pioneer.
I mean just like with porn,
the porn industry,
Pioneer Dvds.
When DVDs were first the thing,
who do you think was
doing the most advanced?
Like multi-angle interactive.
The experiences was the point of this,
right?
I mean we always had phones wasn't going
to go with that old style of video.
All the porters like,
cool,
we'll have to,
yeah,
exactly.
I never did the rest of them totally.
I mean we're always going to be
driven by sort of our sexual desires.
Kurzweil says we'll be able to tap into
each other's nervous systems and become
each other when we have sex with her.
That's girl finding with
someone actually merging.
Well,
but no,
but some people say,
you know,
the Kama Sutra talks about,
we've been wanting to merge with
our lovers at the beginning of time.
I want to become one,
but it says in Him we can actually
scramble our nervous systems together.
Imagine allision man device or whatever.
I remember.
That's good.
That could be a real mind fuck though.
If you just find out that you
aren't like the worst in bed ever,
you feel what it's like
to be fucked by you?
Shit,
look at me.
I'm this og.
Why am I doing?
That's
even better.
Say it all like it takes
over.
Like,
why am I choking myself?
I won't you let me prove me.
Or even worse,
what if you get into her mind?
Like if you can access your girlfriend's
needs and desires and you got one now
what you want and you get into her mind.
It's just a river of black cock.
She's sleepy river of disembodied
black cops just shooting,
shooting sperm like a,
like a psychadelic dream.
You're brining a river
of dark black coffee,
black caucus,
slippery bro,
hip bull Cox to allow for a lot
of creativity in sort of our,
our,
our sexual consciousness to
a multiplicity of dimensions.
And we can't even imagine it's
the yellow and black psychedelics.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?